Emna Ghariani, thank you so much
for joining me on my
20 Minute Leaders show.
How are you?
Good. How are you?
Fantastic.
It's so great to have you here.
Some technical issues to start, but
that's part of the
virtual lifestyle that we have.
Unfortunately, we can't be in a studio
doing this face to face.
We'll settle for this.
Emna, we have so much to talk about
from your startup Veamly
all the way to digital well-being.
Let's start off easy
and then accelerate as we go along.
Who are you Emna Ghariani?
All right.
Wow, that's a long question.
So, I'm the CEO and co-founder of Veamly.
Veamly is a unified workspace
for developers.
Our goal is to help them focus better,
stay in flow, remove distractions,
so we give them a centralized workspace
for their non-coding apps,
and we give them a smart feed
of their conversations on top.
Are you referring to the fact
that there are distractions
when we are online?
Yes. So, the problem is today all of us,
even beyond developers,
when we open our laptop
our cortisol level is high by default,
our stress is high, our focus is down
just because we have
so many tabs open, so many apps,
and we get interrupted, yeah
We get interrupted every 11 minutes on average
and it takes over 20 minutes
to focus again.
So, when you think about it
we're all the time in non-focused mode,
and we end up staying late
and working over the weekend
and burning out
and we don't ... second
to stop and think pretty much.
So, that's why pretty much.
Now, is this new?
So is this something, if I look at the workforce 50 years ago,
people are working everywhere.
Is this a new problem that we have?
Absolutely.
Actually, it's funny you say that,
because I always talk about
the evolution of communication.
So 20 years ago,
50 years is a bit too far
we didn't have computers like we do today,
at least we didn't use them.
We didn't have computers
like we do today.
So 20 years ago, however,
communication used to happen
via one, two main channels.
Of course, that had a lot of issues
like scattered information, silo effects.
And in the past few years,
we've seen an explosion
of collaboration apps and work apps,
and now there's literally
an app for everything
and there is no streamlined process.
So, we are here
to streamline the process
between all these apps
and help people better leverage
and optimize their time
in the hope to help them
get to their work-life balance.
So, yeah.
But what does that even mean?
So, how do you go
and help people avoid distractions,
optimize their time,
be more productive in the moment?
Very good question.
So, for us, what we do in Veamly,
so it's a desktop app.
So, you have access
to all your different apps
and top you have your smart feed,
but we have a mode
where you can go from sync to async.
So, when you are in async mode
you have no interruptions.
You still have your smart inbox
being filled up
with all your conversations,
and then we have
a soft alert system
to help users understand
that they need to look at something,
but that they're in flow
it's not gonna interrupt them.
And then what we do
is we bring them awareness
on how they're using their time,
and we give them insights
to help them really
educate themselves better.
So with Veamly, they get at least
an hour back a day.
Wow. So, I think that's just fascinating,
'cause as I'm reflecting now
on my experience,
I'm a software engineer
at Hippo Insurance,
and I love the experience.
And one of the interesting things
is that I've noticed that
now that everybody's remote
and there is no casual meetings,
I can't stand up and go meet
somebody at the office,
my Slack messages that I'm getting
I almost feel the responsibility
of answering them
as if somebody came up to my desk
and spoke to me.
And that is distracting because
as I'm coding or doing something else,
I feel compelled to
in real time answer everybody.
It's not like an email
where I feel, okay,
it's fine if I take two, three hours
because I don't check my email
every five seconds, right?
So, I love what you're saying
because for me, it's very interesting
how we as people
don't even take a step back
to think on why we do that even.
Like Slack is not forcing us to go in.
But what happened is the notification sound
or the color ... makes your brain react
before yourself in a way.
So, that creates this fake sense of urgency
and this also FOMO effect, right,
the fear of missing out.
So, before you ...
it's one of your colleagues
sharing a puppy picture
and it's not
... everything is fine,
you're already distracted,
you're already looking at it,
you're already interacting with it.
Beyond that, you also have
your comments on your JIRA tickets
and your comments
on your ... request
and every single thing comes
and it's a notification
or it's an interruption.
And today there is no way to prioritize
to know what to focus on or not.
And it's very detrimental
to your focus, to your flow.
And it's stress
that we don't even feel.
For me, I will say this like
there's two types of stress, right?
And I'm not scientific or a doctor,
but there's the stress that you feel
and there's the stress that you don't feel
that's living everywhere in your body,
in your lower back,
in your wrists, everywhere,
and you don't realize it's happening.
And all these small things
contribute to it.
Sure.
But we're not accounting for them.
That's why we talk about
... productivity in that sense.
So, yeah.
So, what is the actual solution?
It's a desktop application
that I come in and I go into
this new world, this async world,
where now a lot of my messages
becoming self notifications
and smart alert systems.
Tell me a little bit more
about the experiences
that I'll have using that.
Yeah, absolutely.
As a developer
you open Veamly,
you have access to your Slack,
to your JIRA, to your GitHub.
Anytime you need to do
actual work in those,
you'll access them from there.
But on top we have
one single pane of glass
where it's prioritized for you
... what needs your action
and what needs your attention,
so immediately you know
how to prioritize your time
and what to address first.
So, everything else
that's not a priority right now
we'll put it in another tab
and you can go look at it later.
Also, the way we prioritize
is based on the user preferences.
So, as they start, they decide
what goes into their feed,
we're not here to do that.
But also we have obviously
some algorithms to help prioritize
that are, some of them are logical
some of them are smart
based on behavior and semantics.
And so, that's the first level.
And then on top of that,
they have a unified search
where they can search
for any information really easily.
And, as I mentioned,
they have this mode
sync versus async,
and when they are in async mode,
then we have a soft alert system
that doesn't interrupt them
if they're in flow,
but if they're not,
then it will let them know
there is more stuff to look at.
The thing is,
an interruption or a distraction
is not a bad thing.
... actually proven
it was great for creativity.
But it's an unplanned
distraction or interruption
is that's the one that's bad for you.
So for us, we help you
plan your distractions in a way
and prioritize your time
while streamlining
all your communications.
So, give me a little bit of context
and a little bit of statistics,
because I'm sure that that's something
that you've been mixing around.
And so, how many notifications
does the average developer get,
let's say, a day?
Or how much time does it waste?
You mentioned something earlier.
Very good. So people get, developers get
at least a hundred messages a day
across their different apps.
So, this is a combination
of Slack messaging.
- We're popular.
Yeah. And a hundred
is a very small number, by the way.
It goes by very fast.
So, it's a hundred messages
between their Slack,
messages between their comments
on JIRA tickets,
between their comments
on their ... request,
JIRA or whatever other app
obviously they're using.
Yeah.
But their ticketing apps.
So, between those,
they spend on average
two minutes on each.
So, that's a total
of three hours and 20 minutes a day.
And then couple hour meeting,
especially in a remote world,
that's five hours and 20 minutes.
So, theoretically in an eight hour day,
that leaves them
with an hour and 40 minutes
of true focus time,
which of course does not happen.
Unfortunately, the developer community
has always been guilty of not being great
at their work-life balance,
so they tend to burn out pretty quickly.
They don't take days off.
They don't put themselves
at the forefront.
At the same time,
every app out there
that's about developers,
it's all about code.
It's not about product,
it's not about them as people.
So, and for us we're like,
we come from that background.
We built product, we've seen it,
and we want to care about them as people
because as they are more balanced,
everything else will go even better;
more productive, better for the company,
better for everybody.
So, and that's ...
How did you get started
with this whole idea?
So, before this, I used to run a company
doing CPO as a service, so
Chief Product Officer as a service.
So, I'd act like an interim CPO
to non-tech founders,
and I'd bring my team
of designers and engineers,
and then we'd build the product
and take it to market
depending on the needs of the company.
And that's kind of where it hit me,
how the way we work is broken.
And so, based on my background,
I have a lot of background
in process optimization
and communication and ops in general.
So, for me, it was a no brainer
to go after this.
And before that, I did help launch
over 40 startups as a director
at The Founder Institute.
Wow.
So, I've seen the problem
elsewhere as well,
and that's what got me to,
like kind of my path was that way.
Like I helped other companies,
then I wanted to start my own company,
but I wanted to figure out
what I needed to solve for the world.
And that's kind of how I got there.
So, yeah.
Right. Digital well-being
goes side by side with productivity
in the sense that
you're trying to understand
how people engage
with their digital environments,
not necessarily to optimize
their work productivity, right, or output,
but to also maximize their well-being.
Talk to me a little bit about that.
I don't think I know nearly enough,
and I'm just starting out
in my own career,
so this is definitely something
that I want to take with me
as I continue my journey as an engineer,
but also as an entrepreneur
and hopefully leader.
Great. So, digital well-being
is definitely a combination
of different things.
The problem is that
when we try to throw
software at the problem,
I mean that was a weird sentence
but you get my point,
like throwing software
as a solution at a problem,
like this isn't gonna solve it.
I always say this
like Veamly, as a software itself,
is a band-aid;
the true solution is gonna be
what comes with it
which is what we help people achieve.
It's like when you buy
a pack of cigarettes
and it says smoking kills,
that's kind of ... thing to do
to educate people on really
how distractions and notifications
are really killing their day
and their life and their well-being.
Like, for example,
I have been notification free
for almost two years now.
And everybody's shocked-
I'm scared. I'm shocked.
Exactly, right.
You're scared, you're shocked.
And people are like,
"How do you do that?"
Like how, like you're a CEO,
you're running a company,
you're doing all these things.
And I always challenge people
to try it for three days.
The first time you feel true withdrawal.
Like for me the first time,
especially the first three days
when I started, I felt like
something is missing. Literally,
it was almost like a drug.
That's how I realized
how bad it is even more, right.
So, for us,
definitely that's at the core
of what we're doing
in terms of helping people
think differently about those.
But beyond that, it's the small things
that you implement
in your day to day
that help you do better.
So, even being conscious
about the problem,
disconnecting from screens.
like for me, you'll never find
my phone next to me,
and if you find it next to me,
it's always screen down, right.
So, it's like getting in the habit
of reducing distractions.
So, a lot of things enter
in making us more productive
and more balanced,
and that's your sleep quality,
your water intake, even the way-
Wait wait, before we continue there,
I have to go back a little bit
because I have to ask. This idea of no notifications
as a CEO, at the end,
throughout this show
and filming over 200 episodes,
one of the really interesting things
that have been coming up
is this idea of being connected
and being responsive.
A lot of people are really
taking responsiveness seriously.
And it always amazes me
how very, very busy people
respond very, very quickly
to my emails or my messages.
How do you portray yourself
as a responsive person
and not miss opportunities
or allowing people to count on you
in a world where
you're not even aware necessarily
that they're messaging you?
So, first, I love this question
because earlier in my career,
and not that long ago really,
I obsessed over responsiveness,
especially when it's like
somebody qualify as important,
whoever that is, right, in your world.
It could be your boss or whoever it is.
So it's like you're always scared,
"Oh, what if I don't answer,
and they think I'm careless?"
or I'm not, pretty much
it's all fear, right?
It all comes from fear,
at the end of the day.
Fear of missing out,
fear of being perceived wrong.
And the thing is,
I always say this even to my team,
it's all about intent.
That's number one.
So, I think we put the wrong weight
on responsiveness,
because we're not robots.
If I'm not responding to you,
it means I'm probably doing
something else,
I'm responsible for ... right.
So, if I'm working on a presentation,
I'm working on a product thing,
I don't need to be responding to you
unless it's something super urgent
and then you just call me, right,
and interrupt me.
And so the thing is is you realize
that most people don't care
if you reply to something
within 24 hours,
that's when it comes to email, right?
When it comes to instant messaging
like Slack and other things,
like it's a matter of an hour or two
which nobody does,
unless you are in a collaboration mode.
When you're in collaboration mode,
you need to schedule that.
Like I talk about
structured synchronous communication, right.
Like there's a whole debate
about async versus sync.
I'm like sync can be structured, right.
I can be in sync mode,
that's how we have this feature,
and if I'm in sync mode,
all my notifications are coming in,
but it's fine,
'cause I'm in collaboration mode.
So, I never had any issues
with responsiveness
since I've been notification free,
because I still check my different apps
on a regular basis, right.
If I'm done with a task at hand,
then I'm gonna go check
my main channels of communication, right.
So, which is I use
mainly Trello, JIRA, Slack, and email.
These are the four main ... for me.
So, yeah.
And so, when you're running
your company now,
do all your engineers have to use Veamly
to be productive?
I hope that for them.
They're building it,
so if they don't believe in it,
we'll have a problem, right?
So it not even like, for us,
even the whole approach,
whether it's our engineers
or other engineers out there,
the whole point is
we're not forcing something on you.
We're bringing awareness for you.
It's kind of what you said
about yourself, right
right now. It's like I'm an engineer.
I see this as like, yeah,
I want you to realize that for yourself
and hopefully we help you
be more balanced, be more focused
and do better, really.
100%.
So, back to digital well-being.
Go back a little bit to the scope
of what's happening today
and a little bit of where
we can expect to be headed,
especially in covid-19 times
when things are a little bit tricky.
We're not really sure of what's happening,
and we're not really sure
of our interaction
with the virtual environment
for years to come.
So, this is actually,
covid made this problem
even more prominent and bigger,
because now we don't have a separation
between our personal life and our work.
Even for me,
I've been running remote for years, right.
Before this,
I have launched companies remotely
in different countries.
So, but I always made it a point
to separate my work environment
from my personal home,
'cause it's very hard, right?
That's why like
one of the advice you get
is in order to be balanced,
try to have your own space,
try to make, create sort of a routine, etc.
So, back to this digital well-being aspect of it
in this environment we are in,
more than ever we need a sense of stopping,
creating a separation
between our personal life or not.
For me, I talk about
the sense of accomplishment.
I say with Veamly,
the whole point is to get you
to that sense of accomplishment
and remove FOMO.
You know things are there for you,
so you can see data
about how you're using your time,
you know what you have accomplished today,
you know what you need
to be doing tomorrow,
everything is there for you,
it's not gonna go anywhere.
So when you disconnect,
you don't have that stress of like,
did I miss something, right?
So, beyond that
is bringing the other
external factors.
More than ever,
taking care of our health and our sleep
and all these different things
that impact our productivity
are important.
So, for us, when we talk about that,
when achieving digital well-being,
is by bringing those
within Veamly pretty much.
Like how can we give you
ergonomic nudges,
how can we give you like
not just towards how you can improve
all these different things about your day,
organizing your day like a pro pretty much,
in order to get to that balance.
And so like I mentioned it goes from, like for me
my challenge two years ago
was notification free,
this year my challenge is tab free.
So, at the end of every day
to close out all tabs.
And that's harder
because sometimes you go into a meeting
and you forget to go back to do that.
So, I'm still not perfect at it,
but it's so nice,
because it forces me to take
just five minutes
at the end of every day
and make sure I place
the different tabs wherever I need to,
because 90% of the time
you never go back to all these open tabs.
But it's just bad habits.
So, it takes time.
So, that's why it has to be incremental and
we have to be kind to ourselves.
And to achieve true digital well-being,
you need to become aware
of how you're spending your time.
So, awareness sounds like
the number one key,
because for every person
the implementation will likely
be a little bit different
fitting to their own personal needs.
But give me some more helpful ideas
of what I can be doing in my daily life
to have better digital well-being.
And right now,
I have to say it's tough,
because I'm in front of the screen
sometimes 16, 17 hours a day
both as an engineer,
but also running this podcast.
And it's a lot of screen time,
and I want to make sure
that I'm approaching this
in the healthiest way.
So, very good question.
So, there are a few things
you can start implementing
from tomorrow.
First, calendar blocking.
Sounds like trivial,
but it's a very good tool,
because calendar blocking,
it will help you be more intentional
about your time.
'cause awareness is key,
but intent is key too.
We are opted in by default
in our daily lives.
When you subscribe to a product,
you're opted in by default.
In your work,
You don't take a second
to think about
how you're organizing all this.
So, if you ... 10 minutes every night
before the next day or once a week
to block your whole week,
and to make sure to plug your breaks.
Being in front of a computer
for 17 hours, like now what?
You're very young, right, early in your career.
What's gonna happen 20 years from now?
... gonna start having back pains
and carpal tunnel
and all these bad things,
like your eyes are gonna go to hell.
So, all these things
we're not intentional about them.
So, calendar blocking, amazing tool
to help you schedule your breaks
and realize also be even more focused,
because once you have that,
then you have that rewarding aspect.
That's how our brain works.
You have a trigger,
and then you have a reward.
So you know it's like,
Oh, if I'm gonna do this for two hours,
I'm gonna take a 30 minute break,
and then I'm gonna do
something else in that break.
Workout or go for a walk
or watch something,
whatever it is that you like doing.
So, that's the number one.
Two, sleep sleep sleep.
That's super important.
We don't give enough weight
to the importance
of having a good night's sleep.
It's important for everything,
for our focus
but even for our bodies, our health,
even our workout routine,
diet, everything.
So, that's an "easy" one
to also schedule
part of calendar blocking
to be like at this time
And it helps to use technology, right?
For me, technology is not bad;
it's about how you can
leverage technology
to get to your true digital well-being.
Technology is not bad,
but it can be misused.
Exactly.
Right.
So, if you have an Alexa or a Google home
or ... reminder,
put your reminder to go to sleep.
It sounds trivial, but put that.
Create a sleep routine.
Like that's the time you,
okay, before sleeping
I want to drink water,
I want to read 10 pages of a book,
and do this thing.
Create that routine,
and then little by little
you'll get back to it.
The problem is that we are lost,
and we don't know where to get started.
That's where it gets really, really hard.
So, these are some of the few things
you can start with day one.
I strongly recommend
- I love it.
to organize your phone.
I know phones
are our biggest stressors today.
Notifications, also when you have
five pages of 90 different apps
that you don't use anyway.
So, if you take five seconds,
if you see my phone screen,
I have maybe 10 folders,
one that says work tools,
one that's a social one, finance.
And all these little things then
are not too hard to implement.
They accumulate, they accumulate.
They accumulate, and it will create
that incremental change
will add up to be something
really impactful on you.
Emna, this is a wonderful.
Thank you for being so generous
with your time.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Communication, process, and data.
All around ...
So, I'll say
that's my holy trifecta.
So it's like
communication, process, and data,
in the middle, people are the center.
So, yeah.
People are the center.
I like that.
Emna, thank you very, very much.
Best of luck with Veamly.
Stay safe and stay healthy,
and I love the mission.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Take care.